estelle bonjour alors on le voit vous
êtes donc devant le ministère de la
santé
quelles sont concrètement aujourd'hui
les revendications des manifestants eh
bien ils souhaitent tout simplement plus
de moyens alors outre la défense de
l'hôpital public mais professionnels du
secteur médico social a privés ou
publics se mobilisent aujourd'hui pour
plus de reconnaissance ce secteur il
englobe dans de nombreuses professions
les salariés des ehpad par exemple mais
aussi de l'aide à domicile ou encore du
handicap plus de moyens pour eux et cela
passe pas des effectifs en plus des
augmentations salariales du temps de
formation en plus
plus globalement et en ces temps de
pandémie il exige l'arrêt des fermetures
de lits dans les hôpitaux l'arrêt est
des plans à d'économie a aussi synonyme
pour eux de suppressions de poste vous
l'aurez compris à ce sont 1 des
revendications globales sur la
dégradation de leurs conditions de
travail
estelle les manifestants souhaitent
aussi dénoncer l injustice qui touche le
secteur médico-social un pas que les
soignants exactement un maggaiez ans se
sont allés fameux oubliés du ségur de la
santé il reproche tout simplement au
gouvernement de ne pas avoir appliqué à
leur secteur les avancées obtenues dans
le cadre du ségur de la santé et
notamment ce versement de 183 euros
d'augmentation de salaire et bien il
souhaite donc obtenir l'égalité
salariale entre tous les agents et
salariés est d'un même établissement
alors notez un coup trappe contre paris
de nombreuses
de nombreux rassemblements sont prévus
partout en france à nantes à rodez ou
encore à tarbes par exemple pour ne
citer que ces villes
merci beaucoup estelle pour toutes ces
précisions en direct devant le ministère
de la santé à paris vous suivez un pur
rt france
cette mobilisation aujourd'hui du
personnel médico-social dans la capitale
merci beaucoup et estelle